also ein paar Sachen die wir klären
müssen erstens im letzten Video fand
diese Noobs die ganze Zeit draußen und
das passiert mir nicht noch mal okay
es kann sein dass ihr in diesem Video so
komische Flecken an meinem Haaransatz
sehen werdet das liegt daran dass sie
frische färbt sind also das ist vier
Stunden her gewesen sein dass ich meine
Haare gefärbt habe und ich habe gestern
Augentropfen bekommen die meine
sich gemacht haben das hat zur Folge
dass ich nicht richtig gucken kann es
ist nicht scharf wenn ich vor mein
Gesicht halte und alles was weiter weg
ist ist sowieso ja bei mir ein Problem
aber ja ich gucke irgendwie gerade nicht
richtig dass ich dieses Augen Make-up
hinbekommen habe ist wirklich ein Wunder
aber ich bin auch mein Mensch ich wasche
auch nur mit Wasser und wie es sich für
eine gute Person und unsere Gesellschaft
gehört arbeitet man auch wenn man krank
ist okay Leute dieser Kalender der uns
heute erwartet ist wirklich ein
richtiger Banger und da sage ich ganz
ehrlich size matters
ich sehe euch nicht mal mehr der ist
riesig okay
aber er ist riesig also ich mit meiner
Adventskalender Expertise kann sagen das
ist wirklich enorm groß auch wenn ich
ihn heute nicht so richtig gut erkennen
kann und das ist der Startup
Adventskalender von snox das ist eine
Unterwäsche und Socken Marke mit der ich
in der Vergangenheit schon auf Instagram
zusammengearbeitet habe weil ich deren
Produkte wirklich privat auch sehr gerne
trage und die gut findet der Kalender
ist jetzt aber nicht nur mit Unterwäsche
und Socken gefühlt sondern auch mit
anderen Startup Unternehmen eine Runde
Applaus
[Applaus]
und bevor jetzt noch 100 mal Smock sage
möchte ich Euch darauf hinweisen dass
ich diesen Adventskalender selber
gekauft habe von meinem eigenen Geld und
trotzdem ist dieses Video gesponsert und
zwar von immer aufmerksame Zuschauer in
wissen dass ich Anfang des Jahres bei
meinem Frühjahrsputz von Emma
ausgestattet wurde wie beim letzten Mal
könnt ihr auch jetzt mit meinem Code mal
wann es lieb 5% on top sparen und dies
gilt auch schon auf alle reduzierten
Emma Produkte die jetzt übrigens schon
bis zu 33% reduziert sind ich habe mich
mit dem Emma Flip Topper und dem Emma
originalkissen ausgestattet und was soll
ich sagen die Produkte sind 1A ich muss
euch eigentlich nicht erzählen wie
wichtig es ist eine gute Kissen und
Matratzen zu investieren schließlich
benutzen wir sie wirklich jeden Tag und
verbringen sehr viel Zeit im Bett ich
bin auf jeden Fall super happy mit
meinen Produkten da sie individuell
anpassbar sind und ich beispielsweise
ganz anders liegen mag als Timo und ich
den Komfort bekomme den ich für meinen
erholsamen Schlaf brauche und
gemütliche asmr Videos zu drehen ich
habe nämlich auf meinem asmr-kanal ein
Video aus meinem Bett gedreht falls ihr
gerade auch auf der Suche seid euer Bett
neu auszustatten schaut auf jeden Fall
mal bei Emma vorbei neben Top an kissen
und Bettdecken findest du hier auch die
allseits beliebte Emma one
Federkernmatratze bei dieser hast du
nicht nur 10 Jahre Garantie auf den
Federkern sondern kannst sie auch
risikofrei 100 Nächte lang Probeschlafen
wobei Versand und Abholung inklusive
sind alle Infos zu Emma und meinem Code
mal wann es sleep findest du in der
Infobox vielen Dank an immer dass ihr
dieses Video unterstützt und jetzt geht
es weiter zu Recht fragt ihr euch wenn
es das Startup Adventskalender was ist
ein Start aber Adventskalender und warum
sprichst du Startup so komisch aus
kannst du Startup nicht sagen Startup
Startup das ist ein Startup
Adventskalender
und sie haben tatsächlich auch Socken
und Unterhosen Adventskalender also
falls das euer Kind ist könnt ihr da ja
mal schauen aber welches das ist noch
zeiting was ist der unterschied also das
eine ist NOx das andere heißt NOx
sighting 24 startup-türchen mit
hochwertigen Beauty Food und Lifestyle
Produkten also mal wieder eine
zusammenschließung von mehreren Marken
die sich dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie
gegenseitig die Posten verkaufen oder
ich weiß nicht
zu mir aber es ist sonst eigentlich auch
egal wir wollen eigentlich nur den
Inhalt sehen ja ja okay Preis
129 € sparen wir hier was ist hier
irgendwie ein toller Deal zu holen über
300 € Warenwert
okay alles klar und wir beginnen mit dem
Türchen Nummer 16
[Musik]
dorthin ab Christmas cooles Wortspiel
ich glaube
ich glaube uns erwartet hier die
fröhliche Auswahl an allen intermarken
oh mein Gott was ist hier drin okay ne
irgendwas eine Flasche
also Influenza Produkte natürlich Nummer
eins mutige Verpackung an dieser Stelle
der glühfritz ich kenn nur den Schorle
Franz für kalte Abende und heiße Nächte
Glühwein aus Weißwein ein nettes Produkt
um in die Weihnachtszeit zu starten sehr
weihnachtlich freue ich mich wir haben
nämlich Kollektiv ja beim Höffner
Adventskalender entschieden dass so ein
richtiger weihnachtsthematischer
Adventskalender auch was ganz feines ist
ich finde bei den Adventskalendern von
Katzenberger und
Schöneberger alleeisenberger das sind
halt so Produkte die können halt auch
überall drin sein also sowas ist
natürlich nett naja ich mag auf jeden
Fall weißen Glühwein weil er nicht so in
den Kopf steigt Franz weißer Glühwein 2
€ aber wenigstens Startup Kalender ist
wäre so eine Info zu dem Startup
irgendwie ganz nett gewesen oder
das Ding ist der ist so schwer kriegt
das da halt unten nicht mehr rein
Nummer zwei deswegen braucht man die
zwischen Böden ich weiß kostet mehr aber
im Türchen Nummer zwei
das ist Premium
Erdbeere boah sind die lecker was halten
wir vom Produkt ist super
[Applaus]
die sind auch so richtig rot und und
also die sehen so fresh aus obwohl sie
getrocknet sind boah Erdbeere 3 Euro
Nummer drei Pocking gebaut Influenza
Marken everdrop mit everdrop ist es zu
toll zu waschen sorry ich weiß nicht was
mit mir los ist
sind die Drogen thank you for making the
world a cleaner place oder super also
ein Pop-Up Schwamm was ist ein Pop-Up
Schwamm wir werfen hier mit tollen
Wörtern wie Startup Pop-Up um uns rum
dein Schwamm entfaltet sich so weiter
mit Wasser in Berührung kommt dieser
kann aufgrund seines natürlichen
Ursprungs in Form variieren okay
waschbar und biologisch abbaubar und
zwar mit weniger Plastik nicht was 8 €.
man muss Gutes tun dann immer so teuer
sein Nummer vier markenraten ähm Gitti
Gitti Nagellack
okay auf solche Startups habe ich mich
gefreut darüber Kugel taschenreiniger
entfernt Staub flosen Krümel und sein
könne aus deiner Tasche so einfach
bleibt deine Tasche sauber durch
Bewegung und das tägliche Wühlen in der
Tasche nimmt die klebrigen Innenkugel
Schmutzpartikel auf jetzt mal unter uns
stinkt eure Handtasche oder euer
Rucksack auch so von innen der da drin
ist so ein klebekugel ja das ist
ganz oh ganz klebrig aber coole Taschen
Reiniger nein Euro bei dm ich hätte
jetzt gerne zu der sauberkugel bitte
eine duftkugel für meine Handtasche die
nächste toller Erfindung wird sein
[Applaus]
ist das diese Rosenthal Marke die glaube
ich auch Sascha oder offen und ehrlich
mal unter die Lupe genommen haben die
dann so Jade Roller und sowas für ganz
schön viel Geld verkaufen Beautyblender
Vitamin E infused vegan und alles
mögliche es ist schon eine Erfindung ne
richtigen Yoga Studio bin ich ehrlich
mit euch aber nicht wie Räucherkerzen
sondern so wie die Gummimatten und sowas
Termin eh infused wie kann denn da haben
die das einmal so in Vitamin E rein
getunkt trocknen lassen und dann ist das
Vitamin E infused kommen wir nicht ganz
hin ne das ist dieser Rosenthal das sind
die die auch so Roller die du irgendwie
bei Alibaba für 2 € bekommst verkaufen
sie dir hier für 25 €
14,45 € was kostet der Audi
Beautyblender der zweierpark kostet 11
€, also hier bezahlt zu 14:45
Uhr kostet einer 5,50 € wenn man es hat
dann hat man es okay Leute Nikolaus was
kriegen wir für Nikolaus das Nikolaus
Türchen ist sehr groß
ah Kinder wollt ihr wissen was oh das
ist eine lustige Idee nee das ist das
finde ich okay netzte Nikolaus hat man
ja entweder Socken die gefüllt werden
oder Schuhe und dann Socken von snocs
ist sehr sehr logisch und die sind toll
ich trage die immer wenn ich mir so
einen kuschelige Zeit machen möchte wie
gesagt nicht bezahlte Meinung hier aber
ja sehr gut muss man nur aufpassen ne
e
sag's 10 € pro Stück aber die hätten
kleinen Schoko Nikolaus hätten sie damit
reinpacken können Nummer 7 ich habe mich
vorhin gefragt wie viele Kalender kann
ich öffnen bis es mir langweilig wird
und ich glaube ich könnte das den ganzen
das ganze Jahr über machen es wiederholt
sich natürlich hier passiert jetzt nicht
wirklich was Neues aber das stört uns
nicht in der Nummer 7 befindet sich
Kollagen plus Tabletten sind wir wieder
bei der Apotheke Hyaluron und
Q10 mit Magnesium und Zink und
vitaminare 12C Dings alles deswegen wäre
ein Zettel mit einer Erklärung gut warum
was macht es was wofür ist es zu
empfehlen
erstmal 20 €. hier ist der Hauptgewinn
was macht es aber ich meine ich bin
grundsätzlich nicht an die
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel aber wofür
Knorpel Timos Knie tut immer weh der
könnte das mal machen bei der
ausprobieren also gar keine
professionelle Meinung hier ne das war
alles was ich hier über dieses Ding sage
rein spekulativ aber das Gefühl dass
diese ganzen Nahrungsergänzungsmittel so
also die machen einfach nur am Ende so
ihren Sticker drauf aber komm komischer
Inhalt so ja Pack da Socken rein
probiere mal diese Socken aus die sind
warm aber probier mal diese Kapseln aus
kommen wir mal weiter mit Türchen Nummer
aha zuckersüße Verpackung 1A wieder
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel Barry cold
Vitamin Zink und Vitamin C Holunderbeere
Vitamin C und Zink tragen zu einer
normalen Funktion des Immunsystem bei
das stimmt wann hat es angefangen mit
diesem Gummibärchen für irgendwas sind
wir Menschen so faul Tabletten zu
schlucken dass wir alles in Süßigkeiten
Snack und dingsform brauchen
[Musik]
am Tag
vegetarisch warum nicht vegan und Nägeln
gleiches wie beim anderen aber hier
gefällt mir mehr die Verpackung und der
Geschmack das sind die die wirklich
alles haben also Kollagen gibt es von
denen auch oder Biotin oder Vitamin B6
und Mönchspfeffer die gibt sogar für PMS
Moment Mensch Pfeffer Mensch Pfeffer ist
gut aber man sollte es eher so
therapieweise einnehmen dass 30 Tage und
dann sollte es also naja 20
30 wir kommen zum Türchen Nummer 9 da
werde ich mich freuen denn das Türchen
Nummer 9 ist dieses Mal auch
riesengroß ich gehe nicht mal schlecht
mit diesem Kalender ob man so sieht er
jetzt schon aus
Popcorn yeah meine Lieblingsmischung süß
und salzig wenn ich im Kino gefragt
werde sage ich immer beides
schmeckt mir sogar besser als diese
ganzen Popcorn mit so übelst krassen
schmeckt ne so Toffee und hier und das
noch drauf ich liebe zimple Leute hmm
aber die Frage ne was konntest du was
würdest Du dazu sagen 1
€, oh mein Gott das war das Türchen
Nummer 9 das war mega gut Nummer zehn
wer meine große Box und deine kleine Box
Atelier Brand und das Atelier
brandlinger macht
Schmuck das ist ein wirklich mega cooles
Design ne aber auch für jemanden
und dann tätowiere ich mir noch
unendlichkeitszeichen und dann ist es
mega cool jetzt
ignoriert mal wie ich die Kette jetzt
persönlich finde und ob ich sie tragen
würde oder nicht weil ich habe jetzt
schon drei Leute im Kopf die sie
bestimmt gerne tragen tolle Kette haben
ungefähr die gleichen Preise wie Paul
Valentine ich gern sage Paul Valentino
39 Euro Nummer 11
ja natürlich freue ich mich über noch
mehr Reis ich habe schon den reishung
Adventskalender ausgepackt und da war
genau das drin warte mal ein Kilogramm
kostet 8 € und 250
150 Halbzeit
ihr Menü ganz kleine Affe mich ja willst
du noch irgendwann mal größer wir kommen
dich mal aus
kleine die will noch ganz groß werden
die Kerze Marrakesch Marokko
[Musik]
wir machen fünf Euro okay 5 € normal 13
hier haben die was rein gestoppt ah auch
so ein klassisches also habe ich schon
oft im Kalender gesehen Siegfried London
Rheinland drygen der Literpreis ist
ungefähr 60 € und hier haben wir 40 ml 3
€ 40 in die Boxen sehen aber schon gibt
damage aus klar natürlich warum sollte
man nicht auch ein Produkt in sein womit
ich nichts anfangen kann bartöl falls es
da draußen jemanden gibt der
zufälligerweise meine Videos guckt und
zufällig euch gerne in den Kommentaren
und schreibt kennt ihr mit diesem
Produkt aus das ist gut das ist nicht
gut hauen das eure Leinwand malzi voll
26 Euro und dabei habe ich nicht mal
einen Bart ich freue mich schon auf die
Zeit dir zu anbrechen wird die ist ja
jetzt schon auch gibt aber es wird
wahrscheinlich immer mehr werden dass
Männer sich so richtig schön pflegen ich
sehe Timo so oft mit seiner trockenen
Haut der hat eigentlich eine gute Haut
aber im Winter und so das wird einfach
trocken der muss sie pflegen der muss
Creme ran ne das sieht ein bisschen
gelungen ist ein bisschen Aussehen 15
ist ganz flach weißt du was drin sind
ich glaube es ist eine Unterhose kann ja
gar nichts drin sein
oder doch der thermounterhose finde ich
toll was ist das
ein Tasche ohne tolle kosmet auch hör
mal sabine ist die toll das ist genau
das was ich brauche immer so ein
bisschen was dabei haben und dann ab in
eine andere Tasche aber sieht aus wie
die mamputsch 25 €, wow
was erwartet uns
Hintertürchen Nummer 16 ob wir richtig
richtig stehen richtig richtig
sehen Alice im Bärenland da kommen ich
weiß auch nicht ich kann dieses Zeug
nicht mehr sehen nimm dir ein bisschen
Müsli mach ein bisschen Joghurt rein
machen Löffel Honig wenn du das isst und
dann hast du ein gutes Frühstück diese
Erfindungen dieses hunderte Pulver und
ich weiß gerade gar nicht warum ich so
dagegen gehe jetzt ist bestimmt ganz
tolles Startup autem es tut mir leid
einfach was ich mache jetzt 2 € so doll
kann ich mich ja nicht verschätzen bei
der größten in der Nummer 17 gibt es
ganz toll ich habe keine Ahnung aber wir
machen das einfach mal auf komm auf
unsere Reise
sind noch was ist das was so das ist ein
Tattoo auf dem why not steht das ist
halt insta ist eine Tattoo ey das sah
aber sorry mit diesem Bio Papier und so
das sah aus also ist toll das sieht aus
wie irgend so ein keine Ahnung Samen in
die Erde und sonst was aber also für
diese eine Tattoo ich werde da jetzt
nichts das ist also das umsonst 18 wie
viele Pancakes soll ich mir noch machen
der baking
toll die haben sich dieses Jahr auch in
alles reingepackt 1,70 € machen wir 2 €
gebe ich den Nummer 19 ihr wisst doch
wie sehr ich Beute Liebe und dieser
Beutel ist bestimmt was ganz besonderes
antiplastik Crew ja nachhaltige
Pflanzentopf okay
ich musste kurz lesen Potpourri ist eine
Marke die Blumentöpfe und Blumen
verkauft aber das Besondere ist dass die
Blumentöpfe von Potpourri sich in der
Erde auflösen das heißt man steckt sie
einfach nur rein und dann zersetzen die
sich ist cool also ein cooles Startup
Idee aber Beutel ich weiß schon ganz
genau wie es abgelaufen ist
ja genau wir machen ja diesen
Adventskalender dieses Jahr und wollt
ihr noch eine Position kaufen bzw habt
ihr Produkte die ihr da reinpacken könnt
und uns von guten Preis verkaufen könnt
nee ja Blumen ist natürlich blöd ja klar
Beutel für die 19 haben wir noch nix ja
dann nehmen wir Beute ich habe das
Gefühl wir befinden uns in einer Krise
in einer Klimakrise auf jeden Fall
plastikfreie Becher gute Idee aber
solche Sachen ich glaube wir sind
eigentlich in der beutel-krise ich gucke
gerade auf dem Beutel während ich euch
über den Beutel erzähle und
wahrscheinlich kann ich noch irgendwo
hingucken und den nächsten Beutel sehen
vielleicht ist es auch nur ein Vanessa
Problem und ich bin wie Tommy Schmidt
der das jetzt auf alle bezieht aber
uns mache habe ich 5 € drauf
Squeeze Pack soll ich mir jetzt hier
Espresso Rosso Kaffee Bio Haselnussmus
mit Kaffee und Datteln da Haselnüsse
dattelpulver haferpulver Kaffeepulver
also ja es ist schon so ein Muse so eine
witzige Idee zehn Stück kosten 14 € 1
kostet 1,50 € 21 ist groß und rollt sich
besser im Glas sie ist besser im Glas
weiß ich nicht ist Tee nicht besser in
so einer Papierverpackung aber lass uns
nicht über Verpackung reden okay
Weihnachts Tee mit Zimt und ab
3,50 €, 22 wir sind jetzt auf der
Zielgeraden oder haben wir
ah
das ist doch eins zu eins was man den
Wildpark Schwarze Berge an die Tiere
verfüttert oder
Hundefutter Hundefutter Hunde das ist
Hundefutter es ist wirklich Tierfutter
ich mag so kurz davor es aufzumachen und
es zu probieren
enges Rind von unserer lieben Influenza
Marke Pets delei letztens schon insta
Story gemacht in der ich mich darüber
lustig gemacht habe dass ich mir
vielleicht mal ein Tier holen sollte
weil alle Influenza Youtuber online
Personen mit Tieren mit pepsilight
zusammenarbeiten und ich da da geht mir
da geht mir Geld Flöten da muss ich auch
wirtschaftlich denken und ich hätte
tatsächlich auch gerne einen süßen Hund
ich hole mir nur keinen Hund weil ich
mir nicht sicher bin über die Aufgabe ob
ich diese Aufgabe gewachsen bin aber
wenn sie andere Leute in meinem Alter
schon Kinder holen können dann werde ich
mir jetzt wahrscheinlich auch mal
langsam Hund holen können oder fürs
hundefuttereiges 80 Cent das vorletzte
Türchen wir haben uns hier durch diesen
Start aber Münsterländer durch geöffnet
und haben uns teilweise gefreut und wir
haben echt gemischte Gefühle aber das
stört uns nicht denn wir werden von
snogs noch einmal mit Socken belohnt 43
bis 46 na da wird sich Timo freuen 10 €.
jetzt ist er leer und jetzt machen wir
das 24 Türchen auf es ist Weihnachten
wir laufen zu unserem Kalender öffnen
ihn in der Hoffnung etwas Tolles für
diesen wunderbaren Tag zu bekommen
und dann kommt uns joko Winterscheidt
mit seinem Sushi Bike entgegen und gibt
uns aha noch eine andere Marke Hipp Weg
Rip Cassis eine Bauchtasche leider in
einer Farbe die ich nicht so schön finde
nee lass mal 25 Euro das wäre toll
gewesen wäre ne cool man kann sein
Fahrrad gewinnen die Auslosung findet am
24.12 um 22 erwischt hat das heißt man
muss wirklich das Türchen öffnen und
damit machen das geht da nicht irgendwie
noch später boah manche Leute machen
Ihren Kalender nicht pünktlich auf ne
also von der Qualität ist das eine tolle
Bauchtasche und ich werde sicher
jemanden finden der sie gut gebrauchen
kann
okay ich habe ein paar Gedanken zu
diesem Adventskalender
Hundefutter Bad Öl ganz toll ganz toll
zur Not es sich selber ich weiß aber
worauf ihr kleinen Schweinchen wartet
ich soll ausrechnen ne wie viel wir hier
am Ende überhaupt bezahlen bekommen
haben okay ich bekommt ihr 12 Sekunden
später
nee sorry 240 Euro habe ich jetzt
ausgerechnet 300 Euro Warenwert wird
gesagt wir haben 120 bezahlt wir
bekommen unser über 300 Euro waren Wert
wo jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft bei vielen
Produkten konnte ich ihn ja nicht mal
falsch rechnen weil es die
Originalgrößen waren und ich muss mich
schon sehr verrechnet haben wenn ich 60
€ nicht bedacht habe ich habe mein
Problem mit dem Kalender ist dass der
nicht so ein richtiges Zielgruppe hat
das muss ja nicht so eine klar
definierte Zielgruppe wie Mädchen die
Pink mögen Männer die schneller Autos
mögen sein aber Hundefutter ja also
meine liebhable Produkte sind
Hundefutter die Kapseln bartöl die
Tasche der Make-up Schwamm von Rosenthal
der ist unnötig bei solchen Kalendern
bin ich so ein bisschen hin und
hergeworfen es ist halt dann ein
bisschen wie so eine Mystery Box kaufen
man kann ja sich die Firmen und Marken
und sowas durchlesen die man da drin
finden wird aber ja es ist ja immer so
eine Mystery Box du gehst ja nicht hin
und hast 120 € und gibst für diese 120 €
etwas aus und bekommst das was du haben
willst sondern es wird dir Mystery mäßig
etwas gegeben wenn ich dann halt
Hundefutter und so bekomme dann habe ich
was für mein Geld bekommen aber nur auf
Teufel komm raus also ich finde wir
sollten hier weggehen gerade auf meinem
Kanal zu diesem Gedanken ob man wirklich
eins zu eins was für sein Geld gekriegt
hat weil ich glaube darum geht es am
Ende gar nicht oder sollte es nicht
gehen das sollte er darum gehen ist es
eine tolle gesamterfahrung als dass ich
immer wirklich gucke habe ich jetzt auch
wirklich meine 63 € rein bekommen die
ich ausgegeben habe weil am Ende ist das
glaube ich gar nicht so wichtig ihr
wisst glaube ich worauf ich hinaus
möchte ne wenn das 180 Popcorn in dem
Kalender dein Highlight ist dann weiß
man ja schon Bescheid nein das ist ein
guter Kalender mann ich will den jetzt
auch gar nicht so rosten aber doch
natürlich ist es ein guter Kalender ja
ja ja ich freue mich über die Popcorn